after what feels like forever daniel
craig swanson as british secret agent
james bond is approaching he has
everything we know about no time to die
the 25th bond film no time to die was
originally scheduled for release in
november 2019 but when original director
danny boyle dropped out due to creative
differences it was pushed back twice
then covert 19 arrived and no time to
die was delayed to april 2021 becoming
the first tentpole movie from a major
franchise to be delayed due to covert
19. finally universal pushed no time to
dive back once again to october 8th
betting that more movie theaters will be
open in the fall no time to die has a
big cast with many returning characters
along with some exciting new additions
many 007 franchise mainstays will be
back including ray fines as m ben wishaw
as q naomi harris as money penny rory
kinnear as tanner jeffrey wright as cia
agent felix leiter and leia cedu as mi6
psychiatrist madeleine swann christophe
vaults will also be reprising his role
as fillon and stavro blofeld who was
captured at the end of spectre and is
now in mi6 custody newcomers include
bohemian rhapsody star rami malik who
will be playing the villain of no time
to die he actually named lutz di safin
lashana lynch will play nomi a new
double o agent who joined mi6 after
band's retirement and anna de armas will
play paloma a cia agent who teams up
with bond to battle saffin those behind
the camera are just as important as
those in front of it when it comes to
film and television projects kerry joji
fukunaga the genius behind true
detective season 1 directed no time to
die this marks the first bond film for
the director for which he also co-wrote
the screenplay alongside neil purvis
robert wade and flea bags phoebe waller
bridge purvis and wade work together on
the screenplays for the world is not
enough die another day casino royale
quantum of solace skyfall and spectre it
would have been shocking not to see
their names on the credits and
thankfully they were fully on board to
write daniel craig's last film as
double-oh-seven the film is also
executive produced by chris brigham who
boasts work like inception and argo you
also can't have bond without producer
barbara broccoli whose second credit
ever was licensed to kill and has worked
on every bond production since the past
isn't dead
the trailer gives us a few hints of what
to expect from the movie years after the
events of spectre a retired 007 is
recruited by his old ally felix lighter
for one more mission soon bond discovers
that a man named saffin is behind a plot
that could kill millions of people as
for what saffin super villain schemers
specifically we'll have to wait until
october to find out in terms of themes
fukunaka believes that no time to die is
the culmination of all bond has become
daniel craig's james bond has been
through a lot from the death of his
lover and casino royale to the
destruction of his childhood home in
skyfall it appears that craig's final
chapter as bond will see the character
confronting his many many demons and
possibly getting something like closure
until the next bond comes along anyway
this will be the final chapter for
daniel craig the daniel craig led
doubles seven films are widely popular
for their theme songs which always
managed to capture each movie's overall
tone adele skyfall theme was an academy
award winner and sam smith also nabbed
an oscar for his spectre theme song
writings on the wall it's no surprise
that no time to die will feature a theme
song by one of the decade's most
prominent artists billy eilish the young
singer provides the vocals for the song
also titled no time to die the track was
released in october 2020 putting its
debut and the films almost one year
apart additionally the great han zimmer
serves as a composer of no time to die
marking the legendary musician's first
work on a bond film
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]